nearly week-long prison escape ended
last night for a convicted murderer but
not before leaving even more doubt in
safety for nearby communities good
evening to you I'm Brian Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez the man escaped on Friday
but the public wasn't told for almost
four days and those living closest to
the southern desert Correctional
Facility fear it could happen again
reporter Ryan Matthey joining us now
live from the Las Vegas shuttle
Corporation near Owens and East Eastern
where the convict was recaptured last
night right Denise and Brian you
remember last night we were first on
scene here for that recapture our 8 news
now investigators are confirming he's
back in the custody of the Nevada
Department of Corrections rather than
just the county but before all of this
those living in Indian Springs had One
Singular restless night unaware that
this man had been on the run for several
days a lapse in communication they want
answers for
42 year old porfidio Duarte Herrera the
convicted murderer of a deadly 2007
bombing caught by Metro Police while
boarding a bus to Mexico Wednesday night
he escaped from the southern desert
Correctional Center last Friday about 40
miles Northwest of Las Vegas but 10
miles the other way in Indian Springs a
rural community oblivious to the nearby
Escape it's not acceptable some here
like Maureen Elkins found out over
social media more than three days after
the Escape I'm super scared that dude's
killed people high school students like
Landon blood learning about it through a
school email Tuesday afternoon there's
plenty of places for him to hide out
here and parents like Brittany Mitchell
and William Tillman fearing for the
safety of their and others children did
not know that I mean that's
that's that's betrayal they're not the
only ones shut out U.S Marshals and
Governor sisalak saying they were not
alerted for over three days too exactly
why is unclear the Nevada Department of
Corrections not answering eight news
now's questions since Tuesday and not
present for a press conference Thursday
afternoon what do you think needs to
happen then with the Department it needs
to be reconstructed the people in town
fearing it could have ended much worse
question the consequences of not knowing
again they need to tell the public I
don't know if there's something going on
inside trying to keep it under wraps but
this then yeah step it up
now Governor sislak says there's now an
active investigation questioning this
lapse in communication and those in
Indian Springs believe they could have
actually helped find this guy sooner if
one they knew who to look out for and
better yet to look out for anybody at
all reporting live near Owens and East
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now